meriem djebbour est responsable de
l'animation cinéma des larmes
ce qui n empêche pas de le tenir la
caisse quelques fois l'idée c'est
effectivement qu'on soir à des postes de
responsabilité et aussi qu'on soit en
contact avec notre public
il n'y a pas de sous tâches en fait aux
carmes et je trouve qu'en plus d'être au
contact du public c'est une tâche plutôt
valorisant c'est vraiment la tâche la
plus sympa on a un public et sympathique
quoi avec lesquels en plus un public
très fidèle qu'on connaît bien avec
lequel on se tutoie donc pour nous c'est
vraiment là un peu la récréation d'être
en classe ce matin là comme tous les
matins le cinéma accueil des scolaires
pour une éducation à l'image
trente mille élèves parents de la
maternelle au lycée vous avez combien
d'élèves g37 vous êtes en salle 2 et
sont tous là et moi je l'entends lieu
d'accueil la caisse est aujourd'hui bien
plus que ça depuis l'arrivée du
numérique en 2013 tout est informatisé
le métier de projectionniste a disparu
et c'est à partir de là qu'est ce que
sont lancés les fils s'appelle un tms
et j'ai un retour cabine donc là les
films ne sont pas partis je sais qu'ils
sont programmées en automatique et
ray semblablement ils partent
automatiquement dans cinq minutes si moi
je veux prendre la main dessus je passe
en manuels et je peux lancer
manuellement les films j'aurais perdu ce
matin là trois films au programme dont
le génial l'homme qui rétrécit vieux
film fantastique américain sorti en 1957
aussi monsieur vous assure que vous êtes
en parfaite santé
il arrive que l'on perde du poids sur
mon régime alimentaire anti c'est
possible ça ne s'était encore jamais
vues responsable des événements des
soirées débats des avant-premières
meriem djebbour est en contact permanent
avec les distributeurs
je trouve que c'est possible une c'est
un jour faut que je regarde mon faux je
regarde mon planning de d'événements en
fait mais sa femme semble possible et
orléans et après les films faut les
garder pour l'été parce que je vois qu
hier un été avec coo par exemple ce
jour-là elle négocie deux semaines de
cinéma japonais pour l'été prochain
ça peut nous intéresser parce que c'est
l'occasion d'avoir un petit focus sur un
cinéma en particulier c'est
essentiellement du cinéma contemporain
japonais
ça permet de proposer aux spectateurs
photo ça permet de proposer des films un
peu différent
le cinéma des carmes n'est pas un
endroit neutre
ici les choix de programmation sont
assumés ou efforts et certains films ne
trouveront pas leur place ici
évidemment que je choisis tu sais que la
question d'avortement et très remise en
question aux états unis en ce moment et
il ya un film qu un peu pro life qui est
sorti et je me disais mais alors si on
se retrouve film fait des millions
d'entrées là bas et si on se retrouve
avec ce film là et tu te dis mais
évidemment le fera et pacino raciste et
pacino homophobes on n'est pas un cinéma
de gauche mais on a ce n'est ma
progressiste
[Musique]